In this video, we'll do
some basic data analysis
using our WHO data.
To access a variable
in a data frame,
you always have to link it to
the data frame it belongs to
with the dollar sign.
To see this, let's
first try typing Under15
and hitting Enter.
R responds with an error.
That's because R won't recognize
this variable name since it
doesn't know to look
in the data frame WHO.
Now type WHO$Under15
and hit Enter.
This outputs the Under15
vector of the data frame WHO.
We can compute some statistics
about this variable,
such as the mean, using
the mean function and then
in parentheses
typing WHO$Under15.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
This tells us that
the average percentage
of the population
under 15 is 28.7.
We can also compute
the standard deviation
using the sd function.
So type sd and then in
parentheses WHO$Under15.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
This tells us that
the standard deviation
of the percentage of the
population under 15 is 10.5.
We can also get the
statistical summary
of just one variable using
the summary function like we
did before for the
whole data frame.
To do this, we can type
summary, and then in parentheses
WHO$Under15.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
This gives the minimum
value, the first quartile,
the median value, the
mean, the third quartile,
and the maximum value
of the variable Under15.
The first quartile is the
value for which 25% of the data
is less than that value,
and the third quartile
is the value for
which 75% of the data
is less than that value.
This output tells us that
there's a country with only 13%
of the population under 15.
Let's see which country it is
using the which.min function.
So we can type which.min
and then in parentheses
our variable WHO$Under15.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
This returns the
number 86, which
is the row number
of the observation
with the minimum
value of Under15.
To see which country is in row
86, we can type WHO$Country,
for the country name, and
then in square brackets 86,
and hit Enter.
So Japan is the country
with the minimum percentage
of the population under 15.
Now let's see which country
has the maximum percentage
of the population under 15.
We can do this with
the which.max function.
So type which.max and then
in parentheses WHO$Under15.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
This tells us that
the 124th observation
has the maximum value
of the variable Under15.
We can look up the country of
the 124th observation by typing
WHO$Country and then
in square brackets 124.
Close the square
brackets and hit Enter.
So Niger is the country
with the maximum percentage
of the population under 15.
Let's now create a scatter plot
of GNI versus fertility rate.
You can do this using
the plot function.
So type plot and then
in parentheses WHO$GNI,
the variable we want
on our x-axis, comma,
and then WHO$FertilityRate, the
variable we want on our y-axis.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
A scatter plot should appear.
Income, or GNI,
is on the x-axis,
and fertility rate
is on the y-axis.
Each point in the scatter
plot is a country.
We can see that most
countries here either
have a low GNI or a high GNI
but a low fertility rate.
However, there are
a few countries
for which both the GNI and
the fertility rate are high.
Let's investigate.
We'll use the subset function
to identify the countries
with a GNI greater than
10,000, and a fertility
rate greater than 2.5.
So go back to your R console
and then type Outliers--
this is what we'll call
our subset-- equals subset,
and then in parentheses WHO
comma GNI greater than 10,000
and FertilityRate
greater than 2.5.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
When we used subset
before, we only
had one condition
to define which
observations to
keep in the subset.
Here we have two conditions,
separated by the and symbol.
This means that
both conditions must
be true for all
observations in the subset.
We can see how many rows
of data are in our subset
by using the nrow function.
So type nrow for number of
rows, and in parentheses
the name of our
subset, Outliers.
This tells us that there are
seven countries for which
the GNI is greater than
10,000 and the fertility rate
is greater than 2.5.
Now let's output just
the country names, GNI,
and fertility rate of
these seven countries
to investigate further.
There's an easy
way of doing this,
and we'll use this technique
several times in this class
when we just want to extract a
few variables from a data set.
So type the name
of our data set,
Outliers, and then
in square brackets
we'll make a vector of
the names of the variables
we want to output.
So c, and then in parentheses,
"Country" for the country name,
comma, "GNI" comma, and
then "FertilityRate".
Close the parentheses, close the
square brackets, and hit Enter.
This shows us the values
of these three variables
for the seven
observations of outliers.
We can see that one
of the seven countries
is Equatorial Guinea, a country
that is very rich per capita
due to oil production,
but the wealth
is distributed very unevenly.
In the next video,
we'll see how to create
different types of plots in
R and then build some summary
tables.